Sit down,
take a breath,
and reflect.
I trulythink reflection can help everyone --
people in every industry,
at every stage in one's career,
and in every point in one's life.
Reflection can be done through a
variety of different formats:
purposeful thinking,
written journal entries,
audio notes, pitches,
a discussion with a mentoror honest friend.
The point is to find what works for you
and to make a regular commitment.
Toexamine the events and
experiences of your lives --
what worked, what didn't, and why --
and then, to think about what and how you
would like to do things differently next time.
Sothis might all sound a little fine and dandy,
and may be obvious or trivial,
but the truth is,
so many of us don't take time
out for regular reflection.
But reflection enables you to
focus onwhat really matters,
and to make better choices.